die inspektions nicht ganz einfach
besser schmeckt einfach das war alles
normal läuft überholt findet dori in den
nächsten vier fünf wochen alle vier
filme die bislang noch vor ihm liegen im
animations- sektor wird irgendwie wieder
sehend oder acht erfolgreichste film
aller zeiten sein und man muss sagen das
hat er auch in gewisser weise verdient
es gibt sehr nette rück verweise auf die
handlung von findet nemo und in gewisser
weise entwickelt findet dort auch genau
dieselbe handlung noch einmal und das
kann man wenn man nur froh berlin an den
ersten film hat vielleicht ein bisschen
langweilig finden wenn man es aber noch
genau aber als dann sieht man auch
wiederum wurde film voneinander abweicht
und da wird es dann richtig interessant
im endeffekt passiert noch mal genau das
gleiche es wird eine suche nach den
eltern in gang gesetzt nur dass diesmal
dori ihre eltern finden will und nicht
nemo und dementsprechend haben wir in
einer völlig anderen konstellation zu
tun der nemo erinnerte sich ja ganz
genau an seine eltern und musste lena
sucht laurie dagegen ist der sehr
vergessliche paletten doktorfische
erinnert sich ein überhaupt nicht an
seine eltern weiß nur dass er sich
gehabt haben muss also moderiert suchen
und damit entstehen natürlich andere
probleme als im ersten film und
zugegebener weise witzige in meinen
augen ist es noch dieses becken zählt
korallen welt koran welt korallen welt
ich weiß wo das ist das ist das becken
direkt neben den interessieren wir uns
einfach mitnehmen erinnern dann war da
einmal der clownfisch seine eltern
natori wie eine wunderbare zeit kik war
das ist findet dori anders nemo tritt
zwar auch wieder auf aber spielt gar
keine so wichtige rolle das story steht
diesmal klar im mittelpunkt und damit
natürlich auch die komische aspekte
schon mal gibt's eine nebenfigur mit der
macht der eigentlich alles zusammen ist
ein krake der heißt hank und dieser
krake nennt sich selber einen ich glaube
septimus weil ein oktopus ist dem ein
bein verloren gegangen ist mit diesen
sieben beiden machte aber immer noch
eine ganze menge los
und vor allem kann er jeder bessere
krake seine farbe wechseln und dieser
kreis darum ein meister der tarnung
und es macht ein wahnsinniges vergnügen
auf den bildern zu gucken wo ist der
eigentlich gerade auch dann irgendein
ganz überraschenden ecke auf und das ist
im trickfilm natürlich eine super
möglichkeit mit dieser spezifischen
ästhetik zu spielen
wie kann bist du kann ich bin ratlos uns
in quarantäne
nein wieder da hab ich noch ich muss
meine verordnung durch die störrisch
werden o
es knüpft mit einer ausnahme genau bei
der ästhetik an die auch schon vor 13
jahren im stand was sich auch darin
artikuliert das mit interessenten wieder
derselbe regisseur an bord ist aber es
ist natürlich mittlerweile
dreidimensional
wobei man sagen muss dass das natürlich
den film überhaupt nicht schadet wenn
man sich vorstellt dass man
unterwasseraufnahmen hat mit dem
wunderbaren tiefen staffelungen von
fischschwärmen und sich bewegenden algen
und große korallenriffen und was man
alles ich überhaupt so ein ozean
vorstellen möchte dann sieht das
natürlich in einer intensiveren
tiefenstaffelung wesentlich schöner aus
da die mir gefallen kloeppel ganz nach
hinten wenig raus und kurz mit karacho
in cannes logisch ist es fix ein disney
film die ganze familie sehen ich würde
jetzt vielleicht nicht mit vierjährigen
reihen sehen denn es gibt ein paar
action szenen die nicht wirklich
schrecken erregend sind sagen wir von 6
1 aufwärts für jeden zu empfehlen
man sieht wie vor nicht zu sehen ihr
freut mich zu sehen ich freue mich zu
sehen wie hab schon seit jahren niemand
mehr drin